ich habe mir vorgenommen ab heute jeden
Morgen kalt zu duschen hab so ein paar
Youtube Videos gesehen dass das voll gut
sein soll fürs Herz für ein Kreis auf
generell für ein
[Musik]
Körper ich sitze mit Laser im Auto weil
ich ja
let five nights Freddy gezogt habe in
vir reality auf meinem youtubeekal
absolut bodenloses Spiel gewesen guck
mal wer da oh mein Gott wer ist er denn
ach du scheiße und dieses Video haben
anscheinend die Leute von Universal
gesehen also von dem Filmkonzern denn
die bringen jetzt einen Kinofilm raus
basierend auf dem
computerpiel sind ein paar Kinder
verschwunden was meinst du damit deshalb
wurde der Laden doch
geschlossen die Polizei hat das Freddy
durchsucht hey sie haben die Kinder nie
gefunden was zur Hölle und jetzt haben
die Sandra und mich eingeladen um uns
scheinbar auf den Film vorzubereiten wir
wissen noch nicht genau was passiert
wurden komplett im Dunkeln gelassen und
haben auch ehrlich gesagt beide so ein
bisschen Angst was geht ab grefeld seid
ihr gut drauf oder
[Musik]
was B gegenfahren komm in
Krefeld ja wir drehen jetzt hier auf
jeden Fall irgendwas von dem wir keine
Ahnung haben was wir eigentlich drehen
wir hoffen einfach dass wir uns später
Wiedersehen und wir überleben ja
deswegen wir schalten jetzt mal rüber
was da drin jetzt passieren
wir hallo oh ich hab Schüer also Sandra
darf jetzt Platz nehmen Sandra darf
Platz nehmen ihr werdet jetzt das Spiel
spielen Freddys ihr werdet aber
allerdings in getrennten Räumen sein
aber ihr seid die ganze Zeit über F
verbunden das Ziel ist du musst die fünf
Nächte überleben darfst nicht sterben
dann habe ich Sandra das Spiel erklärt
und wurde rüber geführt so WN ich die
jetzt Pranken Kön wenn wir Licht
ausmachen können oder keine Ahnung oh
mein Gott dein Platz oh du bist der Game
Master nein aber ich sag das nicht dass
ich hier bin was sage ich denn dass ich
auch Spiel ja okay Sandra hörst du mich
ja ich hö dich ich sitz genau an so
einem Setup wie du und hier wurde mir
dann die prankmas zentrale erklärt okay
also ich sch quasi Sandras Bereich da wo
sie ist genau e die
armeer ich kann nicht ich piss mir die
Hose jetzt sind hier so Lichter im
echten Raum mach mal links die Tür hoch
und drück mal
Leid Tür zu Tür zu Tür zu ja ja Tür
zu unterhalt dich mal mit mir junge wei
wie viel sch ja s ich habe hier selber
zu tun gerade in meiner Welt ich herzk
ich Herz guck mal
jetzt dir bei Gott ich habe gerne F Tage
hinteriner Kater aber das ist mir zu
viel mit diesen Lichtern und ich sitze
auch in diesem Raum als wä ich in dem
Raum kann es sein dass du dumm bist lu
ich schwöre dir wenn ich erschreck wer
ich krieg
Herzinfarkt la wenn ich real erschreckt
werde du musst mich nie wieder fragen ob
irgendwo hin mitkomme das war das letzte
Mal dass ich irgendwo mit dir hingehe
passiert denn irgendwas um dich rum wir
spielen nichtichter verrückt diger hier
ist Nebel dir ist Nebel wie kommt das
die ganze Zeit die
gan was ich kann nicht mehr ich schwö
dir ne ich muss raus ich kann nicht
mehr s ich ich komme mir wird gesagt ich
soll rübergen zu dir ich weiß nicht was
bei dir abgeht aber ich geh mal kurz
rüber zu dir
okay Automat die ganze Zeit verrückt
ichn das nicht also ich hat Puls von 70
vor 4 Minuten
100 wir machen noch eine Nacht ich würde
sagen dann tauschen
[Musik]
okay das ist einfach nur ein Spiel
was
Problem du willst
abget Licht brauchst du nicht anmachen
die Türen sind ja geschlossen lass die
Türen so lass Licht aus Licht aus links
das verbuch mehr Strom warte oh mein
Gott
a hey Sand bei mir ist gerade Konfetti
in die Luft geflogen
hier oh mein
gottwegt ich kann Karate ich kann
[Musik]
Karate nein ich bin raus bitte nicht
erschrecken
bitte ich kann nicht
mehr oh mein Gott ganz schlecht
[Musik]
auf im Keller kam die
Figur die ist hier runtergegangen hier
rten
ja nicht guckenät ich gesagt da war die
Figur aus dem Spiel die ist
runtergegangen so Musik habe ich noch
nie gehört aus dem Schlimmsten
Horrorfilm auf einmal lich da aus
ja so viel Nebel ich sehe zwei Augen
leuchten mit Hörner und ich habe
geschrieben wie eine Verrückte und der
ist dann zurückgegangen ja cool das
alles was ich dainten gedrückt hab dann
auch hier ankam mit der Musik und mit
dem Nebel und allen
[Musik]
möglichen e ich wusste es auch nicht wir
wurden hier reingelotzt ja hast ja
mitbekommen ne wo die uns das hier
gezeigt Spiel ja guck mal da hinten ist
mein
bereichz du hast mein ganzen Raum
gesehen guck mal hier ich konte hier
achte mal auf die CS ich konnte hier mit
Licht anmachen ich konnte Konfettikanone
machen diee ich direkt zu Beginn
angemacht einfach nicht gemerkt das
ist ich bin tot meine Nerven sind am
Ende ich war wirklich kurz vor den
Tränen diger Freddy super Film ich wer
mir so die Hose scheißen ich mir auch
Bruder
geisterkinder die von riesenrobotern
Besitzer greifen wie kann man sie
aufhalten gar nicht es ist zu spät was
ist das hier für eine
Kommandozentrale ich habe alles einfach
hierm mit
gesteuert du kriegst das so zurück diger
ja das ist ge
wier nie wieder ich komm nie wieder also
mir auf jeden Fall Spaß
gemacht Sandra
stop was
oh mein Gott ja ich f guter weil ich es
[Musik]
kann so bodenlos Alter die hat ein Pizza
komplett für sich alleine und noch
Nudeln bestellt aber Coke Zero wegen
grüz ich kurz coole Szene wieder wie wir
[Musik]
gehen wir sind jetzt hier im Podcast
Studio angekommen Sandy natürlich am
Start Elias am Start Josef am Start am
Start noch Alkohol da irgendwie so
Getränke da ob den Tannenbaum bitte
vergiss nicht den Tannenbaum Tannenbaum
seit Z Jahren shady falls du diesen Blog
hier siehst kannst i langsam mal wieder
abholen jusf kann übrigens mit seinem
Tesla über die App
[Musik]
furzen an der Stelle würde ich den
heutigen Blog jetzt allerdings auch
beenden
weil ihr seht schon meine Augenringe ich
glaub ich brauch Schlaf undon daher geht
an der Stelle noch mal ein riesiges
Dankeschön an Universal Pictures raus
dass sie das heutige Video
freundlicherweise unterstützt haben es
war eine mega geile Coop also zumindest
für mich ich glaube Sand hat nicht so
gefallen ihr solltet euch jetzt einfach
nur noch ganz dick hinter die Ohren
schreiben ich habe diese Rede W noch nie
verstanden das erbt gar keinen Sinn
warum soll man sich was hinter die Ohren
schreiben das also na ja am 26.10 kommt
auf jeden Fall five nightights Freddy in
die Kinos holt euch eure Tickets gebt
euch den Film und wenn ihr wissen wollt
warum ich mich heute Nacht beim Schlafen
Film abonniert meinen Kanal und das
Video die Tage nicht zu verpassen
ciao